there is also this historical fact that  for a lot of the early 20th century we  did kind of put a pause on immigration  because there was so much and there  wasn't enough assimilation we had a  major milestone today which is that  today year to date we've had two million  border apprehensions in the united  states those are just the ones we got  okay and it's only september so we've  got a quarter of the year left that is  an insane number that that's border  apprehensions then you're gonna have  another million legal immigrants you're  talking minimum three three and a half  six seven hundred thousand got aways  yeah exactly and then and so when you  look at the last 60 years of immigration  you were talking about the largest  movement of people in recorded history i  don't think it it takes a bigoted awful  racist country to say hey maybe that's a  lot of people that you're actively not  assimilating by the way